foreign
[Music]
I know what you're thinking
what the hell is a crypto phone and why
would anyone want that
and that's exactly what I was thinking
when this first crossed my radar so this
is an upper mid-range Android phone with
crazy material choices from a brand
you've never heard of with some specific
crypto features built in that launched
at a thousand dollars now I know I have
been notably uh
skeptical on crypto and web3 and
blockchain and the metaverse and all
that sort of stuff over the past couple
years so you may consider me biased but
I still think if you took the crypto out
of this phone
it would at least have potential
I'm serious let me explain so the story
of this phone actually starts all the
way back with the essential phone so I
don't know how many y'all remember the
essential phone back in 2017 but that
was a really interesting and exciting
new development in the smartphone world
we don't get that many genuinely
promising new phone companies coming
along and doing good things but that's
exactly what this Andy Rubin startup was
promising when they came out with their
first phone it was a just this
refreshing sort of minimal design there
were no protruding camera bumps no big
logos or branding they were one of the
first to do this camera Notch here at
the top of the screen with the thin
bezels and they were one of the only
ones using these super premium materials
the titanium rails and Polished ceramic
on the back and then it just had some
pins on the back with some magnets for
attaching some modular accessories just
some genuinely interesting really cool
ideas on top of some super clean
software now unfortunately this
experiment didn't really catch on you
know this unfortunate combination of of
high price
mediocre cameras not that strong of a
feature set for regular people to care
launching as a Sprint exclusive all of
this led to extremely low sales and then
the company would go on to Dynamite
itself after a bunch of info about Andy
Rubin comes out and so we would not get
to see a second try an essential phone
too now it sucks to see a promising
company with a ton of talent just
disappear like that but something that
happens a lot a lot of times when these
businesses dissolve is the teams that
worked on stuff sometimes will pop up
somewhere else and work on something
else and so sure enough in 2020 a bunch
of the engineers from the original
essential team got back together to form
a new company called awesome and they
would announce their first project the
awesome ov1 basically the spiritual
successor to the essential phone and you
can see a lot of similarities and
continuity in this announcement they
talked about these crazy materials again
this titanium and Polished ceramic and
the rectangular design but they also
then tried to correct a bunch of the
things that doomed the original
essential phone it is noticeably bigger
and with a bigger screen bigger battery
Etc but shocker they didn't really get
enough interest in this brand new
startup phone to be able to bring this
whole idea back to life it's the classic
Enthusiast phone problem where like it's
a cool idea and some people really
really want it but there's not enough
hype to be able to make the whole thing
happen
that is until Solana came along so
Solana is a web 3 company looking for
new projects and awesome is this
Hardware team looking for some backing
to make this phone happen so Solana
would bring the cash and bring their
backing awesome would bring their
Hardware talent and they'd partner
together to turn the ov1 into this
rebranded Solana Saga crypto phone and
it would be a thousand dollars
and uh
that's this one right here so all right
where do we start there's basically
three things that make this a crypto
phone instead of just another regular
Android phone it's the Solana mobile
stack the seed Vault and the d-app store
so okay outside of those things this ov1
or the Solana phone is actually a very
average Android phone like specs Wise
It's a Snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 so that
would be last year's Flagship chip but
then 12 gigs of RAM and half a terabyte
of storage although it's unclear if it's
fast ufs 3.1 but it's a nice big 6.67
inch flat 1080p 120 hertz display at the
front that gets decently bright but it
is not ltpo it's just a fixed refresh
rate and then it's powered by a 4100
milliamp hour battery with wireless
charging not great for the size of this
screen but not tiny and then it's ip68
water and dust resistant with a Micro SD
card slot for storage expansion but then
a pair of really mediocre cameras on the
back it's got the same 50 megapixel main
camera sensor that's in the Rog Phone 7
and the Oppo Find X5 Pro but with worse
software and that's paired with a 12
megapixel Ultra ride camera both of
which can pretty much only produce in
perfect lighting after which Things Fall
Apart very quickly with a lack of detail
excessive noise just no really
impressive strengths just a really very
heavily mixed bag here but there are two
things about this phone that actually
I'm very impressed by that I really like
okay number one
is the materials again just this
world-class build quality because like I
said it's basically the same team the
awesome ov1 team that came from the
original essential phone and so they
have this affinity for super high
quality materials so we're talking matte
stainless steel frame with colored
titanium buttons and a full ceramic back
which yes picks up fingerprints
everywhere other than the fingerprint
reader but dude this phone is a tank
this phone is also very heavy it weighs
like 250 grams which is more than an
iPhone 14 pro Max it's got these nice
squared off sides that I really like
there's absolutely no squeaking creaking
flexing at all it's just this
hilariously well made packaging of these
average specs but then two the other
thing I really like aside from the
crypto stuff the software itself once
you get into it is actually
extremely clean very clean like stock
Android so it is Android 13 and who
knows when it'll get Android 14 if at
all but you can dig through everything
and it is very quick and responsive and
clean everywhere it's the stock Android
Quick Settings the stock Android
wallpaper and customization screens all
these stock Google Apps the the clock
the calendar Chrome everything now does
any of this justify a thousand dollar
price tag
okay well let's see it's got last year's
Flagship spec kind of weak cameras weak
battery not that amazing of a screen but
it's stock Android and good build not
really worth a thousand bucks right so
that's why literally less than a year
after it came out the price plummeted
from a thousand to six hundred dollars
so now the real question is would you
pay would anybody pay six hundred
dollars for uh barely above average
well-built Android phone that happens to
have some crypto features built in
no
I guess this is the part where I have to
go over all of the crypto and web3
features so all right like I mentioned
earlier there's three things that make
this a crypto phone so the Solana mobile
stack is an SDK for apps to connect to
the Solana blockchain which I mean it's
cool that it's built in but the obvious
downside being this does not work with
any other blockchain so no Bitcoin no
Litecoin no ethereum this is just
focused on the Solana blockchain then
the seed vault is basically dedicated
storage of a 24 phrase seed stored in a
secure environment where the Android OS
cannot see them so that would let you
unlock your wallet and then the last
feature is something I've been calling a
d-app store which is literally a second
App Store on this device that's
specifically for crypto apps crypto
Focus stuff so Phantom wallet is on here
uh okx a crypto exchange is on here
Brave browser things like that there's
an app called minty fresh that lets you
turn photos from your camera roll into
nfts in a few seconds and a few clicks
if you're into that I guess but those
are the only three things that really
make this a crypto phone and one of them
the D app store is not really even that
special because it is coming to other
phones and you'll be able to get it on a
non-crypto phone so there's that too now
the other stuff I think you can actually
make an argument is really really cool
to have built into the phone and
actually secure like that and if you are
in the Solana ecosystem this is the only
place you can get that stuff
but man I feel like that's about the
most Niche feature possible like
remember we were just talking about the
Zenfone 10 how I love that phone it's a
super great phone it's just a shame it
won't sell because not as many people
like small phones
do you think the number of people who
are in the Solana ecosystem and want to
buy a phone that has some of those
features built in
is greater than or less than the number
of people who want a small phone
basically the number one coolest thing
to come out of this project to me is
exposing me to this thing right here
which is the uh the cable that comes in
the Box for this phone this is a braided
USBC a usb-c cable but not just any
cable at the end here is a hard switch
that blocks all data and only lets power
through just just making it a charging
cable and that's actually pretty sick
highly effective for preventing
something called juice jacking attacks
where if you plug into like a public
Outlet somewhere but that outlet is
malicious and is going to try to upload
malware to your device or download
photos or something this cable will not
let that happen just blocks all data so
if you're plugging into an extremely
rare public USBC Port this is actually a
great tool to have but it's also not
that special and it's available on
Amazon for like 30 bucks so I'll also
link that below so at this point I don't
even have to really tell you but the
crypto phone is basically a pretty
standard Android phone with a couple
kind of cool but extremely Niche crypto
features for one specific crypto stack
one that happens to also be tanking
pretty hard and has been tanking for
months and I also don't even really have
to tell you that there's basically no
reason for 99.99 of people to buy this
even if you were to try to buy this
phone just for a nice clean stock
Android phone and just totally ignore
all the crypto features you can get a
lot more phone for 600 bucks for the
same price you could get a pixel 7 or
probably pixel 8 by the time it comes
out you could get a refurbished Galaxy
s23 you could get any number of OnePlus
phones I just don't think this is
anywhere near the top of the list for
600 bucks and really that's that's the
shame of it being a brand new phone
company is really hard unless your name
is Carl pay apparently and so I wish
there was a world where the awesome ov1
could just exist and could thrive in a
small Niche Community could love it but
now instead this
becomes the perfect embodiment of crypto
in 2023. at best ahead of its time
but at worst
completely useless to most everyday
people and gives whatever else is going
to follow it and even harder uphill
battle
thanks for watching
catch in the next one
peace
[Music]